It's the approach that Dostoyevsky talked
to his characters when he wrote this
great novels and it's also the approach
that all great novelists taped to their
character because if
you're a great novelist,
you put yourself inside
the head of the murderer,
right,
and Dostoyevsky was great punishment.
For example,
the main character was going to cough
is a lawsuit and he's all upset because
he's lost his faith in God and he's got
all these weird ideas that emerged in
Europe at the end of the 18
hundreds that if there's no god,
everything is permitted,
and so he's thinking,
well,
am I moral just because I'm a coward,
which was a Nietzschean
proposition actually meets,
you said most morality is cowardice.
He didn't say that morality was cowardice.
He said most of the time when
people are being cowardly,
they pretend that it's moral,
which is absolutely right.
Anyways,
he's wrestling with this idea that,
oh,
morality is just cowardice and once
fundamental beliefs have disappeared,
you can do anything you want and the only
thing that's there to stop you is your
own fear.
So that's rattling around
in the back of his head.
Now at the same time,
he's more or less starving to death
and his sister is going to essentially
prostitute herself to raise enough
money so that he can stay in law school.
No,
it's not exactly that.
She's going to go off and marry this guy
that she doesn't love who's quite rich
and she's going to do that
to keep him in law school.
So that's sort of sucks,
you know,
he's not very happy about that.
And then he's living in this horrible
flop house and the woman who runs it is
Dostoyevsky sets this up quite nicely.
She's the sort of person that if
she was run over by a horse cart,
everyone would be pleased.
She's grasping,
admitted at miserly and horrible and mean
and malevolent and cruel and all those
things.
And then to make it even worse,
she has this niece who isn't very bright
that she basically treats as a slave
and tortures in orders
around all the time.
And then she has all these people
who are living in her building,
which she doesn't take care of and she's
just grasping money out of them all the
time.
And she'd have to do anything with money.
She just puts it in a little chest and
she lives like a on bread crumbs and
dust.
And so,
so Dostoyevsky's very careful
to set the situation up.
It's like,
okay,
is there such a thing as right or wrong?
[inaudible] he's pretty
positive about that.
Plus he's hungry and he's drinking
too much and you know he doesn't eat
properly.
Well that's why he's hungry.
And so his head is a little on the adult
side and then he's got this terrible
moral conundrum.
It's like there's this horrible
woman she's torturing and her niece,
and then his sister is going to go into
a loveless marriage and he can't stay in
law school.
And so we rationalize it.
He says,
Oh,
here's a solution,
man.
I'll just get rid of that old woman.
No one's gonna miss her.
Now I'll be doing the world a
favor by getting rid of her.
And then I'll take your money.
And then my sister doesn't
have to become a prostitute,
roughly speaking.
And I get to go to law school
and I'm going to be a good guy.
And so poof.
Perfect.
And if there's no
ultimate right and wrong,
I,
I'm sad.
It's an instrumental argument.
Right?
Well,
so he kills her.
and you have to read the book if
you want the rest of the story.
Suffice it to say that things do
not go exactly as he predicted.
So the first thing he figured this out
is that the person you are before you hit
someone with someone with an ax and the
person you are immediately after you hit
someone with an ax or
not the same persons.
So you know,
he assumes constancy of identity across
every experience that turns out to be
seriously wrong.
So Dostoyevsky man,
and he does such a,
it's a terrifying book.
It's the most psychologically
accurate book I ever read,
I think.
But the reason I'm telling you about it
is this is what made Dostoyevsky's so
courageous.
It's like he,
he generated up a murderer
who is basically him as a
young man and he gave this
kid every reason to murder every,
and he,
everyone,
he could think up,
he tried to make the case for murder
as strong as he could possibly make it.
So he wasn't generating,
not some,
you know,
two dimensional bad guy.
And then he has the,
then he has the argument.